you know I wanted to ask you because
we've done as I counted eight pictures
yeah hesitate before inspector cholera
which means Danny hurry and get sequence
we did two or three more what
joki yeah I'm there one two or three
more
Mexicali guy I like that though I know
it is true and you know I was thinking
when I you know I was one thing we share
in common both of us is we're both jazz
nuts and he grew up in argentina and in
argentina they weren't allowed to
according to the story you told me again
some years ago something is still
accurate that you you had to kind of
pirate the records and listen you know
what happened is they didn't allow at
that time the cells to sell records that
they were kind of they considered
immoral and they thought they just
wasn't morals that was the problem
but it's but it's Americans to own music
you know jazz is the American classical
one of the the true solidly American
artful absolutely and you were you're
great in it and remember the last time
we can festival thing before we were
both playing the piano and you were
playing well I was kind of playing
chopsticks but anyway it was great fun
and I loved him I wish it was a low
throw beer recycle but anyway I just
wanted you you actually you actually
bought the record know that role was
[Music]
suppressed after to for those were the
months that I was listening to modern
jazz musicians on the radio while
driving and I liked it but I could go to
a record store to buy it because it was
forbidden that were and that was you
could do in Spanish if you know in
French music is a universal language
that does not need to touch
it's great and you got this guy right
here I'm gonna take him home what do you
think maybe maybe if you I'll carry it
you get I might put it in the back of
the car it did well he's really nice
talking to you yeah
[Applause]
I want to tell me I want to kill
everybody that claim not only is a great
actor but a great director he directed
one of the movies I scored for ya and
I'd like that well he spotted and we
start here and we stop here that was
very good
anyone be very inspiring yeah just I
still do that one day it falls together
yeah and you're lucky if it falls
together and you have to call Spielberg
oh we can do we can do a trio with speed
will you wear me okay you got this guy
you can just go around and show people
yeah put it on that front of your car
like a cardiac absolutely
it's my honor to present the holo
shiverin with this Oscar